this video was made possible by
skillshare get ahead at work or pick up
a new passion while learning skills for
free for two months by being one of the
first 1000 to go to the link in the
description
this is the nile river perhaps the
single most legendary waterway
in the world it originates somewhere
roughly here
potentially in uganda or burundi but its
tributaries are so convoluted that no
one knows for sure
where its true source is it starts in
earnest though
here on the ugandan side of lake
victoria and snakes northward through
the rest of uganda
and south sudan before entering sudan
and reaching its capital of khartoum
this stretch from lake victoria to
khartoum is considered the white nile
and in khartoum it connects with the
blue nile to become the nile proper
this other tributary starts at lake tana
in ethiopia
and while it's the shorter and
potentially less well-known of the two
it's actually far larger than the white
nile as it carries 85 percent of the
water that flows through the nile itself
of course 100 of this immense river ends
up passing through
egypt now while these may be their legal
borders
for all intents and purposes egypt is
not this
but this some 95 of the country's 98
million strong population
lives within the narrow strip of land
flanking the nile river
truly egypt is the nile and the nile
is egypt almost all of its power and
influence
both modern and ancient is linked to
this
waterway of course much of what most
people know this country for is its past
rather than its present as for nearly
three millennia
ancient egypt was one of the most
powerful and advanced civilizations
on earth of course one can't link the
success of
any society to a single factor but it's
undeniable that
at the time of the height of ancient
egypt's reign agricultural prowess was
directly linked to societal advancement
you could only develop new technology if
you could produce enough food to feed
the thinkers
and egypt could thanks to the nile
every year in august and september the
river would flood over its banks
and then in october it would recede
leaving the floodplains well watered and
fertilized
and allowing for a very productive year
of agriculture
upstream while its stories might not be
as frequently included in the high
school history books
what is now sudan benefited from a
similar effect
the kingdom of kush in particular became
an advanced society alongside the nile
upstream from modern day egypt and still
to this day much of the country's
population
is concentrated in a narrow green zone
along the nile
that's mostly to say egypt and sudan
have benefited through history from this
river in a largely similar way
but then there's the outlier ethiopia
now comparing the satellite images of
egypt and sudan to that of ethiopia
there's a pretty clear difference
ethiopia
is green save for the coast most of
egypt receives less than 10 millimeters
of rain per year
on average this is also the case for
much of sudan
but then in the south the weather gets a
little wetter
the land becomes a bit greener and
dependence on the nile
lowers of course further upstream in the
ethiopian highlands
dependence on this river for water is
nearly non-existent
certain areas receive close to 80 inches
or 200 centimeters of rain per year
which in comparison is four times that
of london
these immense rains in fact end up in
the nile itself
feeding most of its flow and eventually
reached sudan egypt and the
mediterranean
ocean at least that was the case until
the early
1900s at that time colonial powers and
industrialists sought not only to
use the river but to control and
fundamentally reshape it
this began in 1902 with the opening of
the oswan low dam
then continued in the 1910s and 20s with
the development of the single largest
irrigation system
in the world in sudan and as time went
on the flow of the nile became
less and less natural with increasingly
large dams and irrigation projects
it slowly became clear that this was all
more and more
a zero-sum game it became clear that the
flow of the river
was indeed finite
therefore they needed treaties in 1929
the british representing sudan
and a few other upstream countries
reached an agreement with egypt
that in exchange for a number of smaller
concessions gave the country
unconditional veto power over upstream
projects that it believed would reduce
the amount of water to reach them
this was followed up in 1959 with
another agreement that gave egypt the
rights to 66 percent of the rivers flow
sudan 22 and the rest was considered to
be lost to evaporation
through time these and other agreements
created a system where
egypt with the help of sudan was on
paper
the master of the entire river even
beyond their borders
despite their geographic position at the
very end of it
except the one country that was never
party to any of these agreements
was ethiopia where most of the water
originates
still egypt has maintained that the
treaties of 1929 and 1959
are binding agreements underscored by
the historic use of the river regardless
of who was at the table
or who represented the upstream states
under colonial rule when they were
signed
they believe that they have a say in
water projects upstream
outside their borders insofar as the
river maintains the same rate of flow
once it reaches egypt this remained a
nominal issue for most of the 20th
century
but it all changed once ethiopia had
centralized enough power
political will and money to start to
reshape
the nile it all comes down to
development
you see while egypt's historic
development was thanks to the water of
the nile
it's now proving to be a barrier 97 of
the country's fresh water comes from
this river
and while egypt's population has grown
the nile has
effectively shrunk therefore annual
water supply per capita in the country
has halved since 1970 even as the
country's economy has further developed
the un considers any country with under
1 000 cubic meters of water per person
per year
as water scarce egypt has just 570.
it is now more than ever held back by
water for example it has to import
around half of its food
at huge cost to both its people and the
government which subsidizes food
while the nile may have been more than
enough when egypt's population was
two or three or four million thousands
of years ago
it now is far from that as they're
pushing up against a population
of 100 million ethiopia meanwhile
does have significant issues with food
security but not exactly because they
don't have enough water
as most people there live from harvest
to harvest they're prone to food
shortages
from a bad year these semi-regular
famines that ensue
are dramatic but the country has managed
to develop despite them
since 2004 ethiopia's gdp has grown
about 10
per year which is immense in fact
between 2013
and 2018 it became the fastest growing
economy in the world
which is especially impressive given its
large size
much of this growth has been fueled by
one
thing infrastructure investment
they've built a new railway to djibouti
opened east africa's first light rail
system in addis ababa and are planning
the construction of africa's largest
airport
however the story of ethiopian
infrastructure development
is most defined by just one single
project the grand ethiopian renaissance
dam located in the northwest of the
country
this dam once completed will house the
eighth largest hydroelectric power
facility in the world
it will be nearly three times larger
than the next largest on the african
continent
and the reservoir behind it will be able
to hold more water than the entire blue
nile
itself it will be able to produce in a
year
nearly 16 000 gigawatt hours of
electricity
with that it could fulfill the power
needs of 234 million
ethiopians well that would be noteworthy
on its own
it's even more so considering that the
population of ethiopia
is only about 109 million this project
in one fell swoop will give the country
a major
power surplus that is exciting for
ethiopia
for two reasons first it should have
a multiplier effect for development not
only does building and operating the dam
itself provide jobs
but if this energy can make its way to
rural areas especially
it could make certain jobs such as
farming more productive
according to the rocky mountain
institute there's about four billion
dollars in potential economic
opportunity
just from electrifying small rural farms
and making their processes more
efficient
which is the equivalent of about five
percent of the country's gdp
ethiopia has one of the lowest per
capita power consumption rates in the
world
the average american consumes as much
power as 186 ethiopians
and increasing that can and will improve
quality of life
and increase economic growth in addition
to that though
having more power than they need means
that ethiopia
can become an energy exporter the
country
plans to sell power to neighboring sudan
which is also severely energy starved
and eventually egypt djibouti
uganda and tanzania too all in all
according to the world bank ethiopia
could become the largest power exporter
in africa
earning around 1 billion dollars a year
for ethiopia and ethiopians this project
is a physical manifestation of the
country's
stunning inspiring rise and uniquely
it's truly their damn unlike most large
infrastructure projects in the region
this one was largely self-funded by
taxes and bonds
that everyday ethiopians bought that
means that a big chunk of ethiopian
people are financially
and emotionally linked to it and it's
one of the rare unifying causes
in a country defined by ethnic violence
and highly factional politics
to ethiopians the grand ethiopian
renaissance dam
is a powerful force for good downstream
though
perceptions are very very different
in egypt this dam is viewed as an
existential
threat it's a single project that has
the potential
to upend their entire way of life
ethiopia will have the ability to quite
literally flip a switch to control how
much water gets to egypt
and therefore how many people in the
country are hungry or thirsty
well some are concerned that ethiopia
will actually do this and remove water
from the river to use for agriculture
that's not likely considering where the
dam is
being so close to the border with sudan
this would require them to pump water
back
upstream which would be hugely expensive
and impractical
the more real threat for egypt is around
what's starting to happen
now the filling of the reservoir you see
given that the reservoir behind the dam
required to keep the flow consistent
even during drier seasons
can hold the contents of the entire blue
nile itself
the process of filling it could have a
significant
impact on the flow rates of the river
while the long-term process of
electricity generation
won't actually remove any water from the
river as one must run it through
the turbines the short-term process of
filling the reservoir
will likely lead to a period of a few
years when in egypt there's less water
for agriculture
drinking and generating electricity the
big question therefore
is how long will the filling of the
reservoir
take for ethiopia they want this to
happen
as fast as possible the sooner the
reservoir is filled
the sooner they can put all their
turbines online and the sooner they'll
get a return on their investment for
egypt though they don't want this to
happen at all but if it does
they at least want it to be filled as
slow as possible ideally in periods of
heavy rain when there's a surplus of
water
in their minds it's going to be easier
to get through a decade or so
with slightly lower flows than just two
or three years with dramatically lower
flows
egypt is also worried about a foreign
power having such immense amount of
control
over them this potentially permanently
gives ethiopia the upper hand
if they don't get what they want from
egypt they can
just turn off the tap both egypt
and ethiopia meanwhile seem to think
that this issue
is worth escalating tensions over even
though to the external observer it's
clear that there is
a mutually beneficial solution on the
western side of the continent
a quite similar situation exists with
the senegal river
this waterways flow originates in the
mountains of guinea and to a lesser
extent mali
two fairly rainy countries and snakes
westward to form the border between
senegal and mauritania
two rather dry countries recognizing
that all four countries were lie on this
river but for different reasons
they formed an organization the senegal
river basin development authority
to jointly manage the waterway for the
mutual benefit of ahol
this organization has crafted
multinational agreements to ensure that
the downstream dryer countries have the
water they need to ensure food security
while also ensuring that the upstream
countries can benefit from cheap clean
power
they built a hydroelectric dam in mali
which shares its power jointly with
martenia and senegal
and then another dam near the coast to
prevent salt water from making its way
upstream into irrigate farmland in
mauritania and senegal
all in all they treat the river as a
multinational asset
they recognize the dependence of
downstream populations on it
and they ensure that any development
upstream is to the mutual benefit
of all member states this can
also be the case for the nile the grand
ethiopian renaissance dam
can benefit ethiopia sudan and egypt
such as through managing the flow to
prevent floods reduce the impact of
droughts
and increase productivity of all
countries dams but
only if they work together the reality
right now though
is that egypt ethiopia and the other
stakeholders
are increasingly far from this goal
egypt maintains a rhetoric that predicts
inevitable conflict if their demands are
not met
while ethiopia has reportedly been
preparing for the prospect of this
by installing anti-aircraft batteries
around the dam
egypt has long been the political master
of the nile
largely because it's historically been
the dominant economy along the nile
and so it seemingly can't accept a
future where that is no longer
the case ethiopia has always been the
natural geographic master of the
waterway
but it is only just now coming to
realize that
without experience in multinational
cooperation over the river
it can't seem to accept much less than
full control
there are really only two futures with
this river
either ethiopia and egypt come to
cooperate and then turn the nile into an
economic engine for the entire region
or they don't and fall further into a
conflict which will hold
them both back this entire region could
have a bright future
but to get on the path towards that they
need to focus on the nile as a tool for
unification
rather than division they need to ignore
the political relics of the region's
colonial past
and forge their own future based on the
realities of today
once they do so the nile could not only
maintain its status as one of the most
legendary waterways in the world
but it could regain its position as one
of the most economically influential
ones
just as it was many millennia ago
as i get ready for a winter with much
more time at home one thing
i'm doing is trying to find more
passions i can pursue while indoors and
one of the ways i'm doing this
is with skillshare of course they can
help you get ahead at work or school
with all their classes on hard skills
like graphic design
but i really want to highlight how they
can also help you have fun
on your own two classes that are a great
example of this
is the one under mixing dance music and
the one on live djing
the first helps you learn a skill that
you can very much do at home then the
second sets you up to use these skills
in the hopefully not so distant future
when things like live djing can happen
again
of course even if you don't think djing
or music production will be your passion
with the thousands of really high
quality classes they have there's surely
one that will kickstart something to
captivate you
over the next few months whether you
want to become a music producer
a youtuber a musician an illustrator an
artist or anything skillshare is the
place to start
and it's at no risk to you assuming you
become one of the first 1000 to go to
the link in the description
as you'll get two months of learning on
skillshare for free and you'll be
supporting wendoverproductions
while you're at it